>>> WE NOW SEE ALEAR
REPUBLICAN DIVIDE OVER T FBI
SEARCH AT MAR-A-LAGO.
MORE SENIOR AND SERIOUS VOICES
IN THE PARTY FOLLOW FACTS.
>> THE FBI IS SIMPLY CARRYING
OUTSIDE THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
UNDER THE LAW, A LAWFUL SEARCH
WARRANT, THAT A MAGISTRATE HAS
SIGNED OFF ON.
AND THEY DIDN'T GO IN THERE WITH
FBI RAID JACKETS.
THEY TRIED TO CONSTRAIN THEIR
BEHAVIOR, CARRYING OUT THAT
WARRANT.
SO, LET'S BE -- LET'S SUPPORT
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
LET'S STAND WITH THEM.
>> THE VOICES LIKE GOVERNOR
HUTCHINSON ARE OFTEN LOUDLY
DROWNED OUT BY THOSE WHO HAPPEN
TO TAP THE ANTI-ESTABLISHMENT
ZEAL OF THE TRUMP BASE.
>> THEY'RE ENFORCING THE LAW
BASED ON WHO THEY LIKE, AND WHO
THEY DON'T LIKE.
THAT IS NOT A REPUBLIC -- WELL,
IT MAY BE, IT'S A BANANA
REPUBLIC WHEN THAT HAPPENS.
>> WITH ME TO SHARE SUPPORTING,
NNEKA HENDERSON, AND SUNLEN AND
WE HAVE SEEN THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY AFTER 11 CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS THEY BACKED OFF AND
SAID LET'S LET THIS PLAY OUT.
YOU HAVE THE VOICES WHO SAY
DONALD TRUMP CAN DO NO WRONG?
>> RIGHT, DONALD TRUMP WHIPPING
UP THE RUN-OF-THE-MILL FOLKS TO
THE FBI TO PEOPLE LMARJORY TAYLR
GREENE SAYING TO DEFEND THE
POLICE AND PEOPLE DOING WHAT ASA
HUTCHINSON DID THERE WHO HAS THE
FREEDOM AND TO BOLSTER THE FBI,
AND GOD FORBID, WHAT SEEMS TO BE
ANTI-LAW ENFORCEMENT WHEN THEY
TALK ABOUT THIS, IT'S QUITE
FRIGHTENING, IT'S DANGEROUS AND
YOU KNOW IT'S SOMETHING THAT
DONALD TRUMP WANTS.
HE WANTS TO STIR UP THIS FBI
SENTIMENT ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND
IT'S A REAL DANGER.
>> REPUBLICANS HAVE LONG PRIDED
THEMSELVES ON BEING THE PARTY OF
LAW AND ORDER.
THEY HAVE IN RECENT YEARS BEEN A
SMALL VOCAL PRESENCE TO TRY TO
DEFUND THE POLICE BUT NOW FIND
THEMSELVES ATTACKING THE FBI AND
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM.
YOU MENTIONED MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, DWUND DEFUND THE FBI.
AND THE LAST PART IS NOT
SARCASM.
>> SURE.
>> BUT THIS IS WHAT YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE, JUST KEEP YOUR
POWDER DRY, REPUBLICANS.
LET'S FOLLOW THE FACTS AND THEN
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE.
>> YEAH, YOU HAVE MITCH
McCONNELL LAST WEEK WHO CAME OUT
WITH A VERY TERSE, SHORT
STATEMENT SAYING -- TELLING THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TO RELEASE
THE INFORMATION.
AND THEN THERE'S THE OTHER WINGS
OF THE PARTY THAT IS MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE AND THAT'S THE
PARTY THAT'S FUELLING THE
OXYGEN.
AND WE KNOW THAT TRUMP -- IF AND
WHEN TRUMP ANNOUNCES HIS
CAMPAIGN.
IT WAS LARGELY FUELED LARGELY ON
A CAMPAIGN OF GRIEVANCE AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT THE RALLY IN
ARIZONA WHERE REPUBLICAN AND
TRUMP ALLIES WERE CAMPAIGNING
FOR THE ELECTIONS AHEAD OF
NOVEMBER.
THERE WAS SO MUCH ENERGY IN THAT
ROOM, FUELED BY THE FBI SEARCH.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT TRUMP,
TRUMP'S ALLIES ARE REALLY GOING
TO JUST, YOU KNOW, SEIZE ON THIS
NOVEMBER.
>> THAT'S A KEEP POINT.
IN THE SENSE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
RALLIES THEY HAVE.
WE'VE LIVED THROUGH THIS
THROUGHOUT THE TRUMP YEARS HE
BELIEVES YOU'RE IN A CROWD OF
8,000, 10,000, MAYBE 20,000
PEOPLE IN ARENA, THAT THAT'S
AMERICA.
IT'S A GOOD CROWD, BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY AMERICA.
IT'S YOUR CROWD IN THE ROOM.
SINCE HE CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR, WE'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE'S THE SWEET
SPOT.
THE HAD CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE, INCREDIBLY
SENSITIVE POSITION, LISTEN HERE
WHERE HE TRIES TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE.
>> DO YOU TAKE HOME DOCUMENTS
MARKED SPECIAL ACCESS?
>> NO.
>> AND YET, YOU'RE CASTING
DOUBT --
>> YOU KNOW, QUITE FRANKLY --
I'VE BEEN --
>> SORRY?
>> I'VE BEEN WITH THE PRESIDENT,
AT MAR-A-LAGO.
I'D BE VERY SURPRISED THAT HE
HAS ACTUAL DOCUMENTS THAT RISE
TO THAT LETTER OF SECURITY
THREAT.
>> BEGINNING THERE,
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT IF THE FBI TOOK
11 SETS OF CLASSIFIED RECORDS
FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
IN THE BEGINNING, A SERIOUS
ANSWER, NO, THEY DON'T BELONG
THERE.
THAT'S WHAT HE'S SAYING, THEY
SHOULD HAVE NEVER LEFT THE
CUSTODY OF A SECURE LOCATION OF
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT BUT
THEN HE TRIES TO BALANCE IT OUT.
>> AND THERE WAS A LONG PAUSE
BEFORE THAT NO, AS HE THOUGHT
ABOUT HOW DO I ANSWER THIS.
AND THE INTERESTING THING, MIKE
TURNER IS NOT REALLY A
BOMB-THROWER.
HE'S KIND OF A STRAIGHTFORWARD
REPUBLICAN.
I WATCHED THAT WHOLE INTERVIEW
YESTERDAY, IT WAS PAINFUL TO
WATCH, JUST HOW HE TRIES TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING THIS
WING OF THE PARTY HAS REALLY
TAKEN OVER, ESPECIALLY IN THE
HOUSE WHERE THEY'RE POISED TO
PROBABLY WIN BACK THE HOUSE.
AND THERE'S NOT A LOT OF SPACE
FOR THESE COMMON SENSE
STRAIGHTFORWARD REPUBLICANS LIKE
MIKE TURNER OR RYAN FITZPATRICK
OR SOME OTHERS WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TELL IT LIKE IT IS, BUT FEEL LIKE THEY CAN'T
BECAUSE OF TRUMP'S IRE.
CNN'S KATELYN POLANTZ LIVE IN
WASHINGTON.
KATELYN, WHAT MORE ARE YOU
LEARNING ABOUT THIS NEW REQUEST
FROM TOP SENATORS?
>> Reporter: WELL, KATE OVER THE
WEEKEND AND TODAY WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF BIPARTISAN CALLS FOR
TRANSPARENCY AROUND THIS SEARCH
EVEN AFTER WE GOT THAT SEARCH
WARRANT ON FRIDAY.
SO OVER THE WEEKEND, WE HAD TWO
HOUSE COMMITTEE CHAIRS SO BOTH
DEMOCRATS ASKING FOR A
CLASSIFIED BRIEFING FROM THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY AS WELL
AS A DAMAGE ASSESSMENT BEING
DONE BY THE DIRECTOR OF NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE AND THEN THIS
MORNING, OUR COLLEAGUE DANELLA
DIAZ ON THE HILL RECEIVED WORD
SENATORS MARK WARNER WHO IS A
DEMOCRAT AND THE CHAIR OF THE
SENATE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
AND THEN MARCO RUBIO WHO IS THE
TOP REPUBLICAN ON THE SAME COME
PITY, THEY SENT A PRIVATE LETTER
TO THE DIRECTOR OF INTELLIGENCE
AS WELL AS ATTORNEY GENERAL
MERRICK GARLAND ASKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
HERE, WHAT WAS TAKEN OUT OF
MAR-A-LAGO.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THE LETTER BUT
HE SAID IN HIS REMARKS, ATTORNEY
GENERAL GARLAND SAID THERE WAS
AN INTEREST ON A SEARCH WARRANT
ON PRESIDENT TRUMP AND AS SUCH,
THE INTELLIGENCE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO SHARE
WITH US ON A CLASSIFIED BASIS
THE SPECIFIC INTELLIGENCE
DOCUMENTS SEIZED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
THERE IS OTHER TRANSPARENCY
EFFORTS THAT ARE HAPPENING TOO
WE'RE WAITING TO SEE IF THERE IS
A RESOLUTION.
NEWS ORGANIZATIONS ARE ASKING
FOR ACCESS TO THE AFFIDAVIT IN
COURT THAT WOULD SUPPORT BE THE
NARRATIVE SUPPORTING THAT
SEARCH.
BUT WE MAY NEVER KNOW WHAT IS
ACTUALLY IN THESE DOCUMENTS.
DONALD TRUMP SAYS HE
DECLASSIFIED THEM BUT THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE HE ACTUALLY DID
THAT.
KATE?
>> KAITLIN, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR LAYING IT OUT FOR US LIKE
THAT.
JOINING ME FOR MORE IS CNN
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR, ELLIE.
WHAT DO YOU SEE IN THE UNSEALED
DOCUMENTS.
WHAT STAICKS OUT TO YOU?
>> SO MANY UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
BUT WE KNOW MORE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING WE
LEARNED ABOUT THE SEARCH ITSELF
IS WHAT EXACTLY DID THE FBI
FOUND INSIDE MAR-A-LAGO AND
SEIZED?
WE SAW THIS DOCUMENT CALLED
RECEIPT FOR PROPERTY THE FBI
FILLS OUT AT THE SEARCH.
THIS DOCUMENT IS 33 SEPARATE
HEADINGS AND SUBHEADINGS OF
ITEMS AND 20 OF THEM ARE
DOCUMENTS.
NOW A LOT OF THEM ARE BOX
LABELED A 1, BOX OF DOCUMENTS.
THE MOST IMPORTANT IS SOME
ENTRIES INDICATE THE INFORMATION
WAS NOT JUST CLASSIFIED BUT
TSSCI.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT IS THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF
CLASSIFICATION IN OUR
GOVERNMENT, TOP SECRET SENSITIVE
COMPARTMENTED INFORMATION.
WE KNOW THE FBI FOUND DOCUMENTS
WITH THOSE MARKINGS INSIDE
MAR-A-LAGO.
THE OTHER THING IS WE KNOW FOR
SURE DONALD TRUMP'S LAWYER,
CHRISTINA BOB WAS PRESENT AT THE
SEARCH, WAS GIVEN THE RECEIPT
AND SIGNED FOR IT AT 6:19 P.M.
ON THE DAY OF THE SEARCH.
>> ALSO, ELLIE, WITH THIS YOU
LEARN MORE ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL CHARGES OF THE CRIMES
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
CONCERNED ABOUT.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH THAT?
>> KATE, ANY TIME PROSECUTORS
EXECUTE A SERARCH WARRANT YOU
HAVE TO SHOW PROBABLE CAUSE
CERTAIN CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
IMPORTANT TO KNOW IT'S LESS THAN
PROOF BEYOND AEN A REASONABLE D
AND DOES NOT SPECIFY ANY PERSON,
DONALD TRUMP OR ANYONE ELSE JUST
SAYS WE BELIEVE THAT THESE
CRIMES WERE COMMITTED.
THREE TIMES SPECIFIED BY DOJ,
ONE, MISHANDLING OF DEFENSE
INFORMATION UNDER THE ESPIONAGE
ACT.
THIS ESPIONAGE ACT DRAWN HAS A
LOT OF ATTENTION BUT THE CRIME
MEANS TO CONCEAL OR MISHANDLE OR
DESTROY INFORMATION THAT COULD
BE HARMFUL TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
THE SECOND ONE IS DESTRUCTION OF
CONCEALMENT OF GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS CLASSIFIED OR NOT AND
FINALLY,
DESTROYING DOCUMENTS BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
THE HANDS OF SOME INVESTIGATORS.
NONE OF THESE RELY ON WHETHER
THE DOCUMENTS ARE CLASSIFIED OR
DECLASSIFIED.
>> IF THERE ARE CLASSIFIED OR
DECLASSIFIED, ALSO IMPORTANT.
BOTH OF THESE ARE TRUE AT THE
SAME TIME.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
>> IN TERMS OF THE FORMAL LEGAL
PROCESS, NOTHING UNLESS MERRICK
GARLAND BRINGS A CRIMINAL
CHARGE.
IF THAT HAPPENS, THESE
DOCUMENTEDS AND MORE WILL BE
TURNED OVER TO THE DEFENDANT IN
ANY POTENTIAL CASE AND THAT
PERSON WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CHALLENGE THE LEGALITY OF THE
SEARCH BUT KATE, WE MAY NOT HEAR
A LOT MORE THROUGH THE FORMAL
LEGAL CHALLENGES FOR MANY WEEKS
OR MONTHS.